sauvé la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les numéros l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes comment ces
mecs-là arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi
je pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inouï tg les gens ne s'étaient des
valeurs de droite c'était des gens qui
travaillent c'est des gens qui avaient
envie de transmettre quelque chose à
leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas une
république parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent la
haine en soi vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrêmement
dur
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
un dimanche sous le signe de la
mobilisation en france quelques 300
personnes se sont rassemblées à paris
pour dénoncer les violences faites aux
femmes et les appelés à faire grève de
tous demain lundi 8 mars date de la
journée internationale des droits des
femmes devant le théâtre de l'odéon ce
sont les acteurs de la culture en colère
qui se sont une nouvelle fois réunis ils
demandent la réouverture des lieux
culturels ainsi que des aides
financières
le sénégal sous la menace de nouveaux
troubles l'opposition appelle à trois
journées de manifestations à compter de
demain
les derniers jours ont été marqués par
des affrontements entre les forces de
l'ordre les partisans d'ousmane sow qu
ils demandent la libération de député au
moins cinq personnes ont été tuées
le médiateur de la république presse le
président macky sall de sortir de son
silence
[Musique]
l'irak restera toujours avec moi le pape
françois a conclu sa visite historique
dont le pays avec une messe devant des
milliers de fidèles à erbil il a appelé
les chrétiens encore en irak à ne pas se
décourager
après mossoul ancienne capitale
autoproclamée du groupe etat islamique
il s'était rendu plus tôt à qaraqosh
localité chrétienne martyrs
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france les femmes
appelés à la grève de tout fondement
lundi 8 mars journée internationale des
droits des femmes et à la veille de ce
rendez vous annuel quelques 300
personnes se sont retrouvées dans la
capitale cet après midi place de la
république à l'appel d'une trentaine
d'associations
elles veulent alerter sur les violences
conjugales notamment accentuée en cette
période particulière de semis
confinement plus largement ils entendent
dénoncer l'inégalité homme femme
toujours une réalité en france selon
elle compte rendu de la mobilisation
avec notre reporter d'un déjà des razak
plusieurs milliers de personnes ont
répondu à l'appel d'une trentaine
d'associations féministes et ici la
place de la république à la veille de la
journée internationale des droits des
femmes qui va donc avoir lieu demain le
8 mars
objectif faire valoir le droit des
femmes parmi elles et qu'elles celui de
ne plus être victimes de violences
conjugales alors plusieurs dizaines de
femmes ont apportés et des pancartes sur
lesquelles elles ont raconté leur
histoire des agressions qu'elles ont dû
subir alors parmi les textes qu'on a pu
lire j'ai été violée à 18 ans par un
pote depuis mes 15 ans je survis violeur
lui est en liberté
je vous propose un sujet d'écouter
plusieurs manifestants
il ya des choses qui sont inadmissibles
comme le fait que nos hommes politiques
ne veulent pas voter le consentement
après quinze ans ça veut dire quoi en
fait
et tous les auteurs de viols qui sont
jamais condamné il ya trop de 7 on est
dans un dans un monde et dans notre pays
le pays des droits de d humain soit
disant et où les droits des femmes ne
sont pas respectés ou la justice ne fait
pas son travail
il ya quand même prof un maquilleur une
femme qui meurt tous les trois jours en
france pays dits civilisés tout de même
et une pour une qui meurt combien a qui
vivent aux côtés d'un homme qui n'aimait
prise kiné qui les traite comme un moins
que rien et je ne veux rien faire parce
qu'elles n'ont pas de boulot les emplois
de demain de formation pour fuir et et
vivre elle même c'est ton sac là
malheureusement il ya encore beaucoup
beaucoup de chemin à faire
y compris au niveau salarial plusieurs
prises de paroles de représentants
d'associations féministes ont eu lieu
tout au long de cet après midi six
places de la république et parmi les
thématiques évoquées la précarité
l'exclusion ou encore les droits des
femmes
à noter que plusieurs hommes ont
participé à ce rassemblement aujourd'hui
et puis sachez également que d'autres
rassemblements sont prévus demain pour
la journée internationale des droits des
femmes le 8 mars drogue et autres
manifestations en faveur des femmes
cette fois ci au pied de la tour eiffel
à l'initiative de la manif pour tous
l'occasion pour les militants de redire
leur opposition à l'ouverture de la pma
à toutes les femmes ils redoutent que la
mesure ne conduise à la gpa la gestation
pour autrui une scénographie était
organisée si avec l'un des symboles de
la république
la célèbre marianne qui se défait de ses
chaînes je vous propose d'écouter la
présidente de la manif pour tous
nous sommes en france mais aussi dans
beaucoup de pays du monde
dans un moment charnière où il est
envisagé de légaliser des pratiques
comme la pma sans motif médical et son
père qui instituerait toutes les
conditions pour une légalisation futur
de la gestation pour autrui
et puis il y à aussi à cette nombre de
personnes d'organisations qui font la
promotion de la gestation pour autrui
or c'est un esclavage des femmes et nous
voulons dénoncer fortement et fermement
et la gestation pour autrui ou tout ce
qui risque d'amener à la gestation pour
autrui
face à un esclavage de la femme comme
celui ci il ne peut y avoir aucune
tolérance face aux risques visite
surprise de la ministre de la culture
roselyne bachelot hier soir au théâtre
de l'odéon occupé depuis jolie par des
acteurs de la culture
ils réclament une réouverture des lieux
culturels et des aides financières
la ministre a dit comprendre leurs
inquiétudes à mon objectif est de
poursuivre la protection de l'emploi
artistique autant que nécessaire nous
poursuivrons nos échanges à tout et
roselyne bachelot pas suffisant pour
mettre fin au mouvement
nouveau rassemblement cet après midi
devant l'établissement les
protestataires disent attendre des actes
cette occupation a démarré sur la base
de revendications de revendications
concernant la pérennité de l'emploi dans
le secteur de la culture et dans tous
les autres secteurs d'activité et
si cet emploi ne pouvait pas être
pérenne au moins d'assurer une
protection sociale à toutes les
personnes qui en ont besoin
et quand nous avons rencontré la
ministre de la culture c'est ce que nous
lui avons indiqué comme revendication
elle n'a pu que les écouter elle ne
pouvait pas faire annonce sur le moment
même donc l'occupation continue
le premier ministre a promis hier de
mettre le paquet sur la vaccination
résultats sur le terrain aujourd'hui
opération de communication du ministre
de la santé de doutes ses collègues en
visite dans un centre de vaccination de
boulogne-sur-mer
les opérations d'injection de masse ont
été lancés ce week-end dans plusieurs
régions le virus circule le plus le
gouvernement qui doit faire face à la
réticence de certains
cyrielle benavides bullion pour inciter
les français à se faire vacciner
le gouvernement multiplie les actions
des deux supplémentaires de vaccins ont
été alloués aux 23 départements
prioritaire depuis jeudi
jean castex et ses ministres sillonnent
les villes les plus touchées par le coït
19 et ce samedi des centres de
vaccination éphémères ont ouverts
partout en france dans 118 en région ile
de france
à l'instar de ce centre en essonne
installé dans les locaux de l'école
départemental d'incendié et de secours
je salue cette mobilisation absolument
exceptionnel que nous sommes venus
ici dans l'essonne constater ici c'est
des pompiers qui en quelques heures ont
monté un centre permettant de vacciner
aujourd'hui quasiment 1000 personnes
malgré ses efforts seulement 38% des
français font confiance au gouvernement
pour faire face à l'épidémie de corona
virus et mener à bien la campagne de
vaccination selon un sondage ifop
réalisé pour le jdd une défiance qui
s'illustre notamment dans les rangs du
personnel soignant
pourtant prioritaire pour les
vaccinations seulement un tiers a reçu
les deux doses pour l'instant que j'ai
pas l'impression qu'on voit le les faits
devaient la vaccination je n'ai pas
encore je me suis pas encore fait
vacciner mais j'ai réfléchi c'est pas
tant pour moi c'est plutôt pour les
patients si je suis malade
du coup je risque de le propager aux
patients enfin ma famille en excès enfin
l'extérieur je pense que tout ce qui est
obligatoire dans le cadre de la
vaccination peut paraître démesurée mais
je pense que vraiment sensibiliser au
mieux les soignants les accompagnons en
leur expliquant le bénéfice pour eux
leur entourage et pour leurs patients
face à tant de scepticisme le ministre
de la santé olivier ferrand a adressé
une lettre aux soignants les incitant à
se faire vacciner pour protéger leurs
patients les cet ordre qui composent les
professionnels de santé ainsi que des
associations ont même qualifié la
vaccination des soignants de devoir
déontologique et si cela ne suffisait
pas
le ministre pourrait effectuer une
saisine du comité consultatif national
d'éthique
en d'autres termes rendre obligatoire le
vaccin pour ces professionnels de santé
est la nouvelle calédonie confiné et
deux semaines après neuf premiers carte
de kovy 19 le territoire faisait jusque
là partie des rares de la planète à être
épargnée par l'épidémie notamment grâce
à des quatorze obligatoire dans des
hôtels réquisitionnés pour toute
personne arrivant du côté de la
guadeloupe les mesures sanitaires se
durcissent le nombre de cas confirmés a
dû variant anglais poursuit son
augmentation
pour endiguer la propagation ça la
préfecture a déclenché un couvre feu
entre 22h et 6h du matin il entre en
vigueur ce dimanche
dakar face aux stigmates de plusieurs
journées d'émeutes
aujourd'hui le calme est revenu mais dès
demain à de nouvelles monnaies
manifestations sont prévues à l'appel
d'un collectif d'opposition comprenant
le parti du député ousman sonko toujours
en garde à vue le gouvernement suspend
l'école pour une semaine le médiateur de
la république presse le président macky
sall de sortir de son silence pour
s'adresser aux jeunes
excellence monsieur le président la
république
il est extrêmement important que nous
renoncions à cette ferveur qui semble
nous habiter lorsqu'un des moments comme
celui ci nous sommes beaucoup plus
poussés par la chicotte que par les
gouttes
nous avons l'obligation de marquer cette
cause parce que nous sommes à votre
disposition pour vous écouter éteindre
votre parole mais c'est la vôtre que le
peuple attend il est important que nous
comprenions que nous devons marque une
pause et parler à notre jeunesse parler
à nos enfants le faire entendre
le langage de la vérité certes mille
celui de la sagesse
cela va dans tous les sens et nous
sommes au bord de l'apocalypse et ces
derniers jours les partisans tous même
son cou sont descendus dans la rue pour
demander sa libération il dénonce un
complot politique
au moins cinq manifestants ont été tués
dans des affrontements avec les forces
de l'ordre
retour sur ces violences jamais juge
depuis plusieurs années au sénégal avec
guy marrot 6 et la mine a diagnostiqué
[Applaudissements]
rarement le sénégal avait connu pareille
embrasement depuis quelques jours des
heurts quotidien oppose manifestants et
forces de l'ordre dans plusieurs
quartiers de dakar ainsi que dans
d'autres villes du pays
pourtant l'un des plus stables d'afrique
de l'ouest la cause de la colère
populaire c'est l'arrestation de cet
homme
ousman sonko sur ces images le député de
46 ans se rendait en grande pompe au
tribunal où il devait répondre
d'accusations de viol portées contre lui
par une employée d'un salon de massage
en pleine crise sanitaire ce cortège lui
a valu d'être arrêté pour trouble public
mais pour les avocats d'ousmane son co
comme pour ses partisans ces accusations
relèvent d'une machination ourdie par le
pouvoir pour évincer un rival politique
devenu gênant l'empêchement pour qu'ils
aillent répondre à la convocation
l'élève encore de manoeuvre donc
maintenant il est clair que l'état de
droit a cédé la place à un état
dépressif que l'état démocratique et
républicain à céder la place
on n'est pas d'état polygame avec des
mets pas que le sénégal n'a jamais connu
il s'avère qu'ousmane son coût n'est en
effet pas un simple opposant jeunes et
éloquence et énarque ancien
fonctionnaire de l'administration
fiscale a bâti sa carrière politique sur
la dénonciation de la corruption
arrivé troisième à l'élection
présidentielle de 2010 9
il est depuis quelques temps le seul et
unique adversaire pressenti de macky
sall en vue du scrutin de 2024 ses
récents déboires judiciaires seraient
donc le glas d'une alternance politique
pourtant les récentes protestations
dépasse de loin le simple cas d'un
opposant les indiens le fais je ne
travaille pas pour 90% des chômeurs
il ya l'ensemble des problèmes accumulés
qui ont fait que les entrants sont
exportés nettement au delà de la
question de la rétention de choco mais
c'est qu'une situation de mon hôte
économique au niveau du sénégal qui a
fait que les uns sont sortis pour
manifester leur a volé ce qui est en
train de se passer ici au sénégal c'est
la démocratie qui est en train d'être
piétiné donc le président macky sall
nous lui avons fait confiance le 23 juin
on s'est battu tout ce qu'aucune accède
au pouvoir aujourd'hui une fois au
pouvoir il fait le même ceux de tous les
présidents africains
face à l'ampleur de la contestation
l'exécutif sénégalais tout en condamnant
les violences a annoncé ce vendredi un
allègement des mesures sanitaires
difficilement supporté par la population
le gouvernement appelle les populations
et toutes les forces vives de la nation
au calme à la sérénité et à l'apaisement
avec l'intensification de la campagne
nationale de vaccination
nous nous mettons dans la perspective et
c'est une annonce que je vous fais de la
perspective donc de l'allègement du
couvre feu sanitaires depuis le début
des heurts plusieurs médias proches du
pouvoir ont été attaqués ainsi que
plusieurs enseignes françaises
l'hexagone est en effet suspecté de
soutenir l'actuel président
les autorités ont par ailleurs suspendu
ce jeudi deux chaînes de télévision
accusé d'avoir incité aux désordres par
la diffusion d'image des violences de
quoi alimenter un peu plus les
suspicions de dérive autoritaire du
pouvoir
dernier jour de la visite historique du
pape françois remirent à qui elle s'est
achevée ce dimanche avec une messe
devant des milliers de fidèles à erbil
ravagée par les djihadistes plus tôt
dans la journée il s'était rendu à
mossoul ancienne capitale autoproclamée
du groupe etat islamique
avant on qaraqosh localité chrétienne le
martyre où le souverain pontife a appelé
la foule à reconstruire et à ne pas se
décourager
trois villes riches en symboles je vous
propose d'écouter le cas de françois
niney là ici en irak
comir de vos frères et soeurs amis et
concitoyens porte les blessures de la
guerre et de la violence des blessures
visibles et invisibles nbc ville et même
au milieu de grande pauvreté difficulté
nombreux parmi vous ont généreusement
faire une aide concrète et une
solidarité aux ports et aux personnes
souffrantes
ceci est l'une des raisons qui ont
poussé à venir en pèlerinage parmi vous
à vous remercier et vous confirmer dans
la foi et dans le témoignage le liban
dont l'impasse en colère la population
manifeste dans les rues de beyrouth
elle subit de plein fouet l'effondrement
de la monnaie nationale et de l'économie
à cela s'ajoutent les divergences entre
les partis politiques pour la formation
d'un gouvernement
le premier ministre par intérim hassan
diab menace de quitter ses fonctions
un moyen selon lui de faire pression
antoine auger scènes de désolation à
beyrouth en marge de la crise sanitaire
le liban s'enfonce depuis une semaine
dans une situation dramatique qui
inquiète jusqu'au plus haut sommet de
l'état
et c'est d'un ton grave que le premier
ministre sortant hassan diab s'est
adressé au peuple
c'est une tentative d'échapper à ses
responsabilités et cela me donne
l'éventualité d'arrêter de travailler
dans le chaos auquel nous sommes
confrontés maintenant pour travailler
sur les problèmes du pays et ainsi faire
pression sur la formation d'un
gouvernement
si cet isolement aide à la formation du
cabinet je suis prêté y avoir recours
même si cela va à l'encontre de mes
convictions car cela perturbe la
stabilité de l'état et nuit aux libanais
hassan diab qui avait démissionné après
l'explosion du port de beyrouth le 4
août 2020 on appelle à son successeur le
premier ministre désigné saad hariri
pour former au plus vite un gouvernement
qui saura mettre un terme aux révoltes
populaires dont la violence s'est
intensifiée en début de semaine depuis
l'été 2010 9 le liban souffre d'une
grave crise économique dont il ne
parvient pas à se relever
la livre libanaise qui ne cesse de
perdre de la valeur fait plonger la
population dans une situation d'extrême
pauvreté
acculé financièrement et incapable de
subvenir aux besoins de première
nécessité
le peuple est à bout le dollar est à
10500 livres libanaises et chacun à
quatre ou cinq enfants à sa charge
ils doivent nourrir ils mettent leurs
enfants dans les meilleures universités
dans les meilleures écoles
et quand les choses vont mal ils les
font partir à l'étranger et ils
emportent leur argent avec eux ils se
font vacciner contre le coronavirus mais
ils ont laissé le pays ouvert pour que
la population crève ou et le peuple
libanais le dollar est maintenant à
10500 livre il va atteindre 15 à 20
mille livres
pourquoi rester chez nous il faut
descendre dans la rue les menaces
d'hassan diab de quitter ses fonctions
et de laisser le pays livré à lui-même
n'ont pour le moment pas été mise à
exécution mais sans réponse des
responsables politiques dans les
prochaines heures
la crise libanaise court le risque
d'atteindre un point de non retour
la suisse adopte ce qui était présenté
comme une initiative anti burqa
le texte a obtenu 51 de 21% des voix et
une majorité de cantons selon les
résultats officiels publiés par le
gouvernement fédéral initialement
proposée par le parti de droite udc il
n'évoque ni la burqa niqab mais à
l'interdiction de se dissimuler le
visage
les affiches de campagne ne laissait
toutefois pas de doute sur l'objet du
référendum texte soutenu par des
féministes et une partie des électeurs
de la gauche laïque un signal contre
l'islam radical selon ses partisans
une initiative zeno fob et sexiste pour
les autres c'est un procès en appel très
attendu s'il s'ouvre demain à paris
celui de la banque privée suisse ubs
condamné en première instance en 2010 9
à verser 3 7 milliards d' euros damende
notamment pour blanchiment aggravé de
fraude fiscale
alors comment s'est organisé ce vaste
système d'évasion fiscale présumée les
explications de katia technique à partir
de ce lundi se déroulera à paris le
procès en appel du bs cette banque
suisse lourdement condamnés en 2019 par
la justice française une amende record
dans une affaire d'évasion fiscale
3 7 milliards d'euros à laquelle on
ajoute 800
de dommages et intérêts pour l'état
français cinq ex cadres et dirigeants du
groupe ont été condamnés à des peines
allant de 6 à 18 mois de prison avec
sursis
les enquêteurs avaient mis la main sur
38 mille comptes offshore de citoyens
hexagonaux représentant un montant de 12
milliards d'euros à l'époque des comptes
du footballeur bixente lizarazu de
l'actrice valeria bruni tedeschi de la
créatrice sonia rykiel ou encore de
l'entraîneur de football guy roux avait
été identifié tous ont depuis
régulariser leur situation
la banque privée suisse a donc été
sanctionné en février 2019 pour
démarchage bancaire illégal et
blanchiment aggravé de fraude fiscale
des fautes pénales d'une exceptionnelle
gravité selon la présidente de la 32ème
chambre correctionnelle christine mais
les ténors du barreau et hervé temime et
denis chemla défendez la banque
helvétique
ils ont aussitôt contesté le jugement
estimant qu'il n'était étayé par aucune
preuve concrète dans un communiqué la
plus grande banque privée du monde a
expliqué avoir respecté et appliqué les
dispositions légales suisses et
françaises
elle a donc fait appel face à cette
défense le parquet national financier
avait dénoncé le festival d'hypocrisie
de la part de l'établissement suisse
pour les mêmes accusations
elle s'était acquitté d'amandes de 780
millions de dollars aux états unis et de
300 millions d'euros en allemagne afin
d'éviter un procès alors en quoi
consistait cette fraude alléguée
la justice reproche à ubs d'avoir envoyé
des chargés d'affaires helvétiques sur
le sol français des marchés de riches
clients lors d'événements mondains
organisés par la banque mais ne
disposait pas de la licence pour le
faire ces transactions étaient inscrits
manuellement dans des cahiers dits
carnets du lait afin de partager les
commissions entre français et suisses
ainsi échapper selon l'accusation à la
régulation
ceci constituerait un système de
blanchiment généralisée de l'hexagone
vers la suisse second grief seuls 1 à 2%
des français en question ont déclaré ces
fonds alors qu'ils doivent en principe
impérativement le faire
ubs est en outre accusé d'avoir incité
ses clients français à diriger leurs
fonds sur des comptes offshore des
contrats d'assurance-vie couvert à
l'époque par le secret bancaire suisse
pour les faire échapper à la fiscalité
française
pour sa défense ubs assure avoir prélevé
restituer un impôt sur ses comptes elle
france l'existence d'une telle fraude a
été révélée à la justice grâce à cinq
anciens employés du ps révolté par les
transactions dont il était témoin l'une
des lanceurs d'alert stéphanie gibeau
ancien responsable des relations
publiques du ps avait été sommé par la
banque un moment critique d'effacer les
données de son ordinateur
elle a refusé et décidé de confier ces
informations aux enquêteurs français
licenciée elle a reçu des lettres
d'insultés a été cambriolée c quinn et
en frais d'avocats et en pure perte pour
elle elle n'aura pas eu droit à un
centime de l'état pour ses bons et
loyaux services
en comparaison bradley birkenfeld
banquier de boston et lanceurs d'alert à
toucher 104 millions de dollars du
bureau des lanceurs d'alerté américain
pour ses révélations sur ubs
comme quoi faire sauter la banque n'est
pas toujours synonyme de butin alors que
va donner ce combat de titans entre le
fisc français le secret bancaire suisse
à l'heure des révélations sur le
luxembourg paradis fiscal prospère au
sein de l'union européenne
délibéré vaudra son pesant d'or
et on termine avec ce concert
expérimental organisé à tel aviv en
israël seule condition pour y participer
s'être fait vacciner et disposer d'un
passeport vaccinale maxime abers après
ses marchés et ses centres commerciaux
israël relança culture 500 personnes
étaient réunies pour écouter le chanteur
pop ivri lider à tel aviv dans un stade
de 30000 places
aujourd'hui nous sommes donc autorisés à
ouvrir notre industrie culturelle avec
des restrictions seulement les
spectacles en plein air c'est pourquoi
nous le faisons dans le stade tout le
monde ici a été vaccinée tout le monde
doit prouver qu'il n'est pas malade et
bien sûr maintenir une distance sociale
entre les couples seule condition pour
assister au concert montrer son badge
verts version israélienne du passeport
vaccinale une preuve que les spectateurs
ont bien reçu les deux doses de vaccins
nécessaires pour les participants c'est
le début d'un retour à la vie d'avant
c'est vraiment un moment incroyable ici
à tel aviv après un an vraiment
désespérante nous revenons à la vie
merci pour les vaccins grâce aux vaccins
nous nous sentons un nouveau vivant nous
avons ouvert les musées dimanche nous
rouvrons les restaurants et certaines
écoles cela marque la fin de cette
période avec la plupart des israéliens
vacciner espérons que le virus tel que
nous l'avons connue est derrière nous
avec 42 % de sa population déjà vacciné
contre à peine 6 en europe
l'état hébreu a pris une longueur
d'avancé sur la vaccination
grâce en partie à son accord avec le
laboratoire pfizer
mais la fin de la pandémie en israël ce
n'est pas encore pour tout de suite
selon les données du ministère de la
santé le taux de reproduction vendredi
était encore de 1.011 malade en
contamine donc toujours plus d'une
personne on y sera
elle signe que l'épidémie ne recule pas
un quatrième confinement serait même
envisagée nous avons quelques semaines
cruciales devant nous il est tout à fait
possible que nous observions une
augmentation du nombre des malades dans
un état grave
devront peut-être imposer de nouvelles
restrictions et peut-être même un autre
confinement parmi les inquiétudes la
réouverture progressive de l'aéroport
ben gourion
il doit permettre aux israéliens de
rentrer voter pour les élections
législatives du 23 mars prochain mais
présente aussi un risque d'importation
des variants britanniques ou
sud-africains l'état hébreu dénombre un
peu plus de 40000 cacti fait près de 700
patients se trouvent en état grave
à ce jour près de six mille israéliens
sont décédées des suites de la maladie
pour 800 mille contamination ici comme
ailleurs il faudra attendre un peu avant
de chanter le retour des beaux jours et
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi je vous retrouve dans une
trentaine de minutes pour un nouveau
journal à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
un certain regain de confiance est rompu
entre le politique et les experts et
même les citoyens on est une société qui
est totalement percuté et on ne peut pas
considérer une démocratie vit
véritablement une amplitude de ses
possibles et notre étude de ses valeurs
quand elle est à ce point confiné est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment on repart à
zéro par rapport à l'année dernière
la société ne survivra pas à une
succession de confinement une société
c'est pas de confinement
c'est la liberté c'est la créativité
c'est le sentiment d'exister
d'appartenir
comment on va réorganiser le monde vivre
avec la pandémie c'est vivre
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même on
vit tous les jours sans faire attention
que tout en dépend c'est l'unité de
mesure de toute chose une convention
admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
coupe
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait